[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vous allez reconnaître sur ces images le
ministre fédéral de l'innovation des
Sciences et de l'Industrie François
Philippe champagne qui a participé hier
à une partie de pêche aux petits
poissons des genoux en compagnie du
commissaire européen au Marché intérieur
Thierry Breton qui est en visite au
Canada alors entre deux prises de poules
amont ils ont discuté de minéraux
critiques de commerce de technologie
quel est le potentiel de cette relation
Canada Europe je leur ai parlé un peu
plus tôt
monsieur breton bonsoir bonsoir Monsieur
champagne bonsoir bonsoir merci à tous
les deux d'être là on va y aller
directement monsieur champagne on
s'interrogeant sur les raisons de votre
visite ici on pense tout de suite à
l'invasion sans migraine par exemple qui
a accéléré les besoins de transition
énergétique du côté de l'Europe or le
Canada le Québec ont beaucoup à offrir à
ce chapitre là qu'est-ce qui vous
intéresse qu'est-ce que vous venez
chercher chez nous d'abord vous avez
raison la guerre en Ukraine qui a été
voulue par Vladimir Poutine au fond nous
a forcé nous a conduit nous Européens à
nous désengager au maximum de nos
dépendances avec la Russie dans tous les
domaines y compris dans les énergies
fossiles donc on accélère la transition
verte et qui dit transition verte
évidemment qu'on va investir énormément
nous en Europe pour avoir les industries
les produits les instruments qui vont
nous permettre de décarboner notre
industrie c'est à dire les batteries
tout ce qui fait les batteries c'est à
dire les éoliennes c'est-à-dire les
panneaux photovoltaïques c'est à dire
toute la chaîne de
solution de l'hydrogène et de
l'hydrogène décarbonée et donc au fond
on veut travailler maintenant très
fortement d'abord avec nous et nos
partenaires européens mais aussi avec
nos partenaires et alliés non européens
qui peuvent nous aider ensemble à
renforcer les chaînes
d'approvisionnement pour dire très
simplement au téléspectateurs au fond on
veut pas quitter une dépendance qui est
énergétique essentiellement à la
réussite pour aller maintenant dans une
dépendance plutôt à la Chine parce qu'on
sait que la plupart de ces matériaux
aujourd'hui sont soit produits en Chine
ou soit un financer en Chine donc il
faut qu'on ait maintenant avec nos
alliés trouver la solution pour
renforcer nos chaînes
d'approvisionnement et de valeur et
c'est ce dont nous discutons avec le
ministre champagne
intéressant monsieur champagne c'est
quand même un gros client potentiel
quand l'Europe cogne à notre porte c'est
toujours une bonne nouvelle par contre
ils ont des besoins relativement urgents
est-ce qu'on est bien positionné pour
répondre à ses besoins-là bah d'abord
c'est de la musique à mes oreilles
d'avoir le commissaire breton qui vient
chez nous parce que ce qu'on constate
dans le monde c'est un ralliement des
grandes chaînes d'approvisionnement et
comme le commissaire le disait nous
c'est bien pour le Canada parce qu'on a
ce que l'économie du 21e siècle a besoin
souvent ça commence par les talents les
écosystèmes les minéraux critiques à la
proximité parce qu'on se disait
justement vous avez vu les annonces
qu'on a fait Volkswagen Mercedes Benz et
ensuite de ça l'énergie renouvelable
parce que là on est on vit deux grandes
transformations d'économie alors la
transformation verte la transformation
numérique et l'action marché parce que
ce qu'on célébrait aussi avec le
commissaire vous savez récemment
l'Allemagne aura ratifié le grand accord
de libre-échange qu'on a signé avec
l'Union européenne qui nous donne accès
à un marché de 500 millions alors ce
parle le commissaire et moi c'est la
résilience et l'Alliance dans la
résilience et cette complémentarité
entre les alliés européens et nous le
Canada je vous dirais que dans cette
nouvelle économie dans cette nouvelle
conception géopolitique économique
évidemment ça joue pour les avantages du
Canada et de l'Europe alors de l'avoir
aujourd'hui de pouvoir continuer à
regarder ce qu'on peut faire dans le
numérique ce qu'on peut faire avec les
minéraux critiques ce qu'on peut faire
avec les semi-conducteurs moi je pense
qu'on est en train de s'allier justement
pour assurer la résilience dans
l'économie du XXe mentionner l'hydrogène
vers monsieur champagne vous savez que
l'hydrogène vert on a publié la
stratégie mais ça nous semble encore un
peu futuriste est-ce qu'on est bien
positionné est-ce qu'on a un potentiel
pour répondre à ses besoins là oui bah
il faut développer des partenariats
c'est pour ça qu'on discute moi j'ai
déjà même envisagé avec certains
partenaires d'avoir un corridor vous
savez on a des grands ports du côté
d'Halifax jusqu'à Québec Montréal
Trois-Rivières on pourrait avoir un
corridor par exemple l'hydrogène qui
nous amène jusqu'au
au Midwest américain alors ça par
exemple c'est des grands projets que je
discuter déjà avec des manufacturiers en
Europe pour voir comment on pourrait
justement amener cette nouvelle économie
là d'hydrogène par exemple dans le
transport parce qu'on sait que une façon
de décarboner et c'est du l'hydrogène
dans le transport l'eau et ça c'est une
opportunité mais vous pouvez imaginer
quand on parle avec le commissaire
européen qui est responsable de tout le
marché européen il y a beaucoup
d'opportunités et je pense que les
consommateurs les consommatrices les
gens qui nous écoutent ce soir veulent
renforcer ses partenariats mais là vous
avez mentionné plusieurs choses bon
l'énergie verte l'hydrogène les minéraux
critiques les batteries monsieur breton
est-ce qu'il y a parmi ces dossiers là
un qui vous semble prioritaire pour
lequel vous voudriez faire débloquer les
choses plus rapidement
beaucoup de priorités mais mais on va on
va se limiter à deux ou trois si vous
voulez d'abord tout ce qui concerne les
minéraux et ça va devenir très important
et quand je dis les minéraux c'est les
matériaux critiques qui à peu près 30
matériaux critiques il y en a une bonne
quinzaine qui sont aujourd'hui au Canada
et leur disponibilités donc on est tout
à fait disposés à voir ce que l'on peut
faire y compris ce qu'il faut investir
ensemble avec des entreprises qui
pourraient être des entreprises
européennes comment on peut favoriser
cela de façon à sécuriser ensemble nos
chaînes approvisionnement ça c'est la
première priorité j'ajoute que il y en a
aussi qui ne sont pas au Canada mais qui
sont importantes et pour l'Europe et
pour le Canada mais aussi pour nos
alliés américains en particulier on peut
toutes passer au terrain rares et il y a
des terrains il y a des gisements de
terre à très importants notamment en
Afrique en ami par exemple et là on
pourrait ensemble aller faire ce qu'il
faut en partenariat avec des grands pays
africains tels que celui que je viens de
citer pour faire en sorte qu'on sécurise
les chaînes également mais qu'on laisse
aussi de la valeur ajoutée dans les pays
parce que voyez-vous notre façon à nous
de le faire c'est pas comme certains je
ne déciderai pas mais vous les
reconnaîtrez qui vont uniquement prendre
la matière et puis ensuite l'emmène en
Chine la raffine et ensuite la revendre
nous on pense que il faut afficher avoir
la respect pour les pays dans lesquels
ça se passe et en particulier partager
la valeur c'est un sujet sur lequel nous
discutons aussi puis le deuxième volet
qui était important vous l'avez vous
l'avez cité tout à l'heure c'est
l'hydrogène vert nous avons décidé pour
atteindre notre objectif de
décarbonation à 2050 de l'ensemble du
continent européen que nous devrions
produire tous les besoins en hydrogène
vert à 50% de nos besoins en Europe et à
50% de les trouver de les offrir à des
partenaires extérieurs et nous pensons
évidemment que le Canada est très très
bien positionné pour cela vous avez
parlé d'un allié vous parlez d'allier
lorsque vous parlez du Canada vous avez
utilisé le même terme pour parler des
États-Unis mais est-ce que la relation
est plus facile avec le Canada depuis la
publication de des règles
protectionnistes aux États-Unis là je
fais référence Wayne
quelles sont les conséquences de ce
protectionnisme là qui vous inquiète le
plus monsieur breton d'abord je voudrais
dire que je suis ici pour parler
évidemment de l'alliance de l'Alliance
transatlantique qui est très important
pour nous autres Européens
transatlantique c'est deux jambes c'est
les États-Unis et c'est le Canada et ça
je ne l'oublie jamais et pour moi ces
deux jambes et deux jambes ils sont
elles sont aussi importantes une que
l'autre c'est pour ça évidemment que je
suis là avec le ministre champagne et
avec ses collègues du gouvernement
maintenant c'est vrai que l'invasion
acte a créé beaucoup de discussions il
faut pas s'en cacher partout y compris
au Canada du reste je crois mais pas que
en Europe aussi ce qui est important
c'est que maintenant les choses sont
faites elles sont dites d'abord ça va
accélérer des carbonation aux États-Unis
donc ça va dans le bon sens on a les
accords de Paris il faut les atteindre
mais voyez-vous il faut aussi que il y a
deux éléments nous-mêmes et bien nous
ayons notre réponse pour que les
entreprises européennes je suis
commissaire européen donc évidemment
investissent en Europe et donc on va
accélérer les capacités de permis de
financement donc on est en train de
travailler à cette à ce paquet
législatif qui va être proposé dans les
tous prochains jours pour faire en sorte
que les emplois pour nous bien sûr ils
doivent être aussi en Europe c'est un
domaine très important on va investir
énormément bien sûr on le fait aussi
avec des partenaires mais c'est
important que se rappeler que quand on
est allié on parle de coopération pas de
compétition et on l'a dit en Europe et
puis le deuxième volet c'est les
subventions qui sont sur les véhicules
électriques là on pense qu'il y a des
des subventions qui sont peut-être pas
compatibles avec les règles de l'OMC
donc on a une discussion qui sont en
cours et j'ai bon espoir qu'elles
aboutissent avec l'Europe monsieur
champagne c'est ça toujours été dans les
plans de resserrer les liens on a encore
une énorme partie de nos exportations
qui prennent la route des États-Unis
l'idée d'une diversification a toujours
été évoquée est-ce que c'est l'occasion
de le faire donc resserrer encore plus
les liens avec le tout à fait vous le
dites et puis là on a le commissaire qui
est avec nous parce que je pense que le
Canada a l'économie du 21e siècle a
besoin elle commissaire breton le disait
par exemple qu'on soit par exemple du
côté des minéraux critiques parce
qu'évidemment ce que vous entendez du
commissaire c'est que s'ils ont un choix
le Canada sera le premier choix
évidemment on a parlé des semis
conducteurs aussi pour amener de la
résilience moi je pense que dans cette
nouvelle économie là ce que vous voyez
c'est un réalignement des grandes
chaînes d'approvisionnement qui qui sont
plus régionales qui qui assure plus de
résilience et je pense qu'à ce moment-là
pour les entrepreneurs québécois on a
toujours dit vous l'avez dit
historiquement on s'est tourné vers le
voisin américain mais je pense que
l'avantage du Canada c'est qu'on a un
accord de libre-échange avec tous les
pays du G7 et le Canada aujourd'hui
quand je parle au grand donneur d'ordre
quand je parle au PDG à travers le monde
aujourd'hui le Canada vous offre un
marché d'un point 5 milliards de
consommateurs sur une base
préférentielle c'est sûr qu'on a des
liens historiques avec nos amis
européens et déjà vous voyez des
investissements vous parlez de
Volkswagen on a eu des gens qui
regardent du côté et essayer de deux
côtés ce matin on était attention par
exemple tu veux faire du recyclage des
batteries une technologie qui est de
chez nous mais qui regarde aller du côté
de l'Europe alors l'idée c'est que vous
savez un peu la science d'aujourd'hui
c'est l'économie de demain alors on veut
faire aussi un pas au niveau de la
science ensemble on veut regarder ce
qu'on est capable de faire parce que le
but finalement c'est comment on peut
innover plus ensemble comme on peut
fabriquer plus ensemble et comment on
peut vendre plus ensemble à travers le
monde et nos alliés européens moi je
pense qu'à un moment où il y a des
tensions géopolitiques où il y a de la
turbulence économique je pense que la
diversification la résilience c'est
vraiment le mot de l'heure aujourd'hui
alors vous comprenez comment je suis
content d'avoir mon ami le commissaire
chez nous pour parler de ce qu'on peut
faire plus ensemble très bien merci
beaucoup à tous les deux c'est déjà tout
monsieur breton monsieur champagne merci
beaucoup pour voir nos émissions en
entier rendez-vous sur la chaîne ici RDI
[Musique]